il est planter le son respectivement
président et rapporteur et donc
conformément un des rapports des vices
présidents sur la manière dont le Sénat
peut optimiser son travail il nous
semble essentiels de croiser les
approches et de pratiquer une sorte de
porosité entre les délégations et les
missions parce qu'au final nos
préoccupations sont absolument communes
parce qu'elles sont celles en
l'occurrence du poids des normes de la
libre administration et de l'autonomie
financière des collectivités et au Sénat
nous avons un principe très simple que
nous adorons parce que nous l'avons
quasiment voté n'est-ce pas monsieur le
Président c'est qui décide paie et vous
comprendrez quand celui qui paye se rend
compte qu'il n'a pas décidé et qu'il
subisse que j'appellerais une sorte de
d'épreuve qui se répètent longuement
même qu'il est censé bénéficier le
principe de libre administration ne nous
interrogions et nous poussions nos
réflexions sur le sujet et la délégation
collectivité territoriale a conduit
récemment avec mon collègue
rémi.tro et le vice-président du cnen
une mission sur ce qu'on a appelé la
simplification
un rapport que nous avons intitulé face
à l'addiction aux normes aux zones
thérapie de choc parce qu'au-delà d'un
certain nombre de dispositions de
transfert ou de mise en oeuvre de
compétences nous nous rendons compte du
poids insidieux enfin du poids financier
insidieux si je puis dire mais fort
lourds des normes qui sont imposées un
peu dans toutes les lois et qui
finissent par coûter quelque chose comme
2 milliards cinq d'euros supplémentaires
en 2000 en 2022 à l'heure chacun sait
que la sobriété qui doit se conjuguer en
matière de
d'urbanisation qui doit se consommer en
matière d'énergie je pense que la
sobriété doit aussi se conjuguer en
matière de finance et que il nous semble
extrêmement intéressant
de poser un regard positif sur la
dépense publique qu'il doit avoir une
justification et surtout une pertinence
et donc nous avons effectué ce travail
encore une fois autour de l'optimisation
de la dépense publique la sobriété de la
norme et surtout cette interrogation
qui est assez qui est teinté
d'irritation sur la libre administration
des collectivités puisque les élus en
souci de remarquable qu'ils sont élus
par une population
grâce naturellement à leur qualité leur
savoir-faire mais un programme qu'ils
ont présenté à leurs concitoyens et que
les élus locaux on la responsabilité de
voir de mettre en oeuvre un programme
dans lequel ils sont engagés on se rend
compte très souvent de l'incapacité de
réaliser un programme parce que sur
cette route d'un État est venu imposer
des obligations sans réévaluation des
dépenses qui avaient été imposées enfin
chacun connaît la tragédie si je puis
dire financière pour les départements du
RSA de la part avec des compensations
faites au moment du transfert mais sans
jamais de réévaluation alors même que
dans la loi 3DS nous avions au Sénat
proposé une clause de revoyure du
transfert du coût du transfert de
compétences considérant contre l'instant
où il y avait le transfert et quelques
années plus tard l'État lui-même s'était
chargé d'alourdir le de la compétence
transférée sans revoir
la compensation la compensation
financière donc nous nous sommes
extrêmement heureux de nous associer à
ce travail qui aura d'autant plus de
pertinence que nous allons bientôt
entrer dans le créneau des projets de
loi de finances et que un regard
aigu pertinent affûté nous sera
certainement utile merci en tout cas à
nos collègues Jérôme Bachir président de
cette mission et Guylène pantin
rapporteur de nous y avoir associé merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
et l'autre
bonjour à tous et merci à toi Françoise
et à ta délégation permanente elle
contrairement à notre mission temporaire
mais on convient importante voulue par
le groupe RDSE et dont ma collègueil est
la rapporteur faudra bien préciser le
prénom aujourd'hui
car le nom pantal est très répandu en
France mais surtout en Lozère surtout
dans la même famille et et
donc merci d'être là mais il faut
pouvoir tout dire les choses
premièrement effectivement la loi de
finances c'est ici on a traitera donc on
est très heureux moi en tant que
commissaire aux finances
avec Bernard delcro de vous accueillir
dans cette magnifique commission que
nous connaissons bien voilà mais plus
plus sérieusement très important la
dernière remarque que tu as faite
chez Françoise sur y a-t-il avoir un
programme on a un peu l'impression et
pas mettez moi cette boutade une boutade
pourra m'apprend à prendre à me
connaître
le président de la République un peu il
était élu son programme on se demande si
les élus locaux ne seront dorénavant
plus aussi élu sans programme tellement
ils n'auront plus rien à décider sur
leur recette et puis tellement leur
dépense pourraient être contrainte et
arriver d'en haut donc il y aura plus de
programmes à faire vu que tout sera
décidé là alors c'est un peu la question
finalement parce que dans qu'on voulait
mettre à jour lors de cette table ronde
qui décide paye mais enfin qui décide et
qui décide quoi et qui paye quoi et qui
paye comment donc voilà c'est une chose
importante nous avons commencé cette
mission évidemment qui sera relativement
courte nous devrions rendre nos travaux
vers la mi-juin
mais le travail lui a commencé avant
avec la délégation continuera après avec
la délégation avec la mission l'archer
aussi telle que nous l'appelons et tout
cela dans un esprit de complémentarité
et évidemment pas et c'est plutôt
l'esprit transpartisan qui domine ici au
Sénat vous le savez pour essayer de
produire des dossiers de fonds qui
couvrent tous les aspects et les invités
à la table ronde j'espère pourront et
arriveront à couvrir tous les aspects
juste donc cette évidemment ce principe
c'est cette table ronde est retransmises
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
donc tout ce que vous direz sera retenu
contre vous ou au contraire en votre
faveur et pour votre bonne publicité je
vais donc laisser tout de suite la
parole à Madame la rapporteur Ghislaine
merci merci monsieur le Président cher
Jérôme et puis merci pour cette
introduction et d'avoir mis la Lozère
j'apprécie beaucoup
monsieur le Président
vous avez évoqué les grands enjeux de
notre mission d'information et je vous
en remercie je rappelle que cette
mission est née de la volonté de mon
groupe le Rassemblement démocratique et
social européenne nous souhaitons un
effet mener une réflexion sur l'impact
concret des décisions réglementaires et
budgétaires de l'État sur l'équilibre
financier des collectivités locales
ce sujet me tient à cœur et j'ai
d'ailleurs interpellé le gouvernement
lors d'une question d'actualité en
novembre dernier en effet de nombreuses
décisions unilatérale de l'État viennent
régulièrement affecter les conditions
d'exercices des compétences et des
collectivités territoriales
tantôt ces décisions augmentent les
charges des collectivités tantôt elles
en diminuent les recettes dans tous les
cas elle compromettent fréquemment
l'équilibre l'équilibre des finances
locales dans un contexte dans un
contexte budgétaire contraint marquez
notamment par la hausse du coût de
l'énergie et des matières premières
un des enjeux de notre mission est donc
d'analyser objectivement la situation en
particulier la mise en oeuvre concrète
du principe comme l'a dit le président
tout à l'heure qui décide paix l'article
72 de la Constitution dans sa rédaction
issue de la loi constitutionnelle de
2003 2003 pardon prévoit que tout
transfert de compétences entre l'État et
les collectivités territoriales
s'accompagnent de l'attribution de
ressources équivalentes à celle qui
était consacrée à leur exercice
il en découle que lorsque l'état
transfère aux collectivités
territoriales des compétences auparavant
exercées par lui le législateur est tenu
de compenser celle-ci au coût historique
par l'attribution des ressources
correspondant aux charges constatées à
la date du transfert
le montant de ces charges constitue un
et si un droit de compensation
madame la Présidente chère Françoise
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le cas
du RSA on pourrait également parler de
la compétence de gestion des collèges
par les départements et des lycées par
les régions ces compétences transférées
en 1983 et élargie en 2004 son
compensées comme le RSA au coût
d'historique on évalue le reste à charge
de 3,3 milliards d'euros pour les
départements et de 3,7 milliards d'euros
pour les lycées ces montants évidemment
sont considérables mais les exemples
sont nombreux et je doute pas que nos
intervenants nous en fourniront d'autres
évidemment
je serai donc pas plus longue je vous
propose de céder la parole à nos
intervenants que je remercie à nouveau
d'être venu ce matin pour pour ces
auditions et puis nous aurons évidemment
un temps d'échanges après pour les
diverses questions qui ont des
coloreront donc je vous propose de
céder la parole d'abord
aux professeurs
voilà au professeur monsieur cabanes
professeur de finances publiques a fait
un kit rappel le cadre juridique
applicable à notre sujet je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteur
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président donc il m'a été demandé de
vous présenter rapidement le cadre
juridique et les enjeux juridiques je le
ferai de manière très sommaire
évidemment en trois points le premier
point il s'agit de rappeler même si vous
le connaissez le cadre normatif actuel
autour de trois dates et trois textes
première date évidemment la loi du 2
mars 1982 qui à l'article 102 a prévu un
principe d'une compensation de
l'accroissement des charges de toute
mission qui sont transférées de l'État
vers les collectivités territoriales
cette compensation devant ce faire par
un transfert de ressources c'est
classique c'est la disposition que l'on
retrouve maintenant à l'article 1614-1
du code général des collectivités
territoriales dont on peut retenir je
dirais trois axes premier axe il faut
qu'il y a une compensation intégrale des
charges transférée deuxième axe cette
compensation
de la Somme affectée aux collectivités
doit être évaluée à la date du transfert
et ne pas tenir compte d'amélioration
future troisième axe et bien le texte
prévoit qu'il y a une évalue une
évolution annuelle de la compensation
financière je cite comme la dotation
globale de fonctionnement ça c'est le
premier texte le premier cadre deuxième
texte qui est issu de la loi du 7
janvier 1983 et que l'on retrouve à
l'article L
1614-2 du Code Général des Collectivités
Territoriales c'est un article que l'on
oublie souvent mais il est prévu que
s'il y a je cite des modifications des
règles relatives à l'exercice des
compétences transférées par voie
réglementaire et non pas législatives
par voie réglementaire et bien cette ce
transfert de compétences par voie
réglementaire donnera lieu à une
compensation comme les transferts par
voie législatives puisque le tiret de
renvoie au tirer
troisième texte beaucoup plus proche de
nous la réforme constitutionnelle de
2003 qui a introduit vous le savez un
article 72-2 dans la Constitution et ce
qui va nous intéresser c'est la ligne A4
c'est là que va être le problème je
crois l'alinéa 4 opère une distinction
entre deux choses première chose la
ligne A4 vise les transferts les
transferts de compétences de l'État vers
les collectivités territoriales doivent
être compensées par attribution de
ressources et cette compensation doit
être intégrale et équivalente à ce que
l'État dépensait jusqu'à l'autre ça
c'est la première partie du 72-2 alinéa
4 deuxième élément avancé par le
l'article
72-admiaque de tirer de aïnia 4 le cas
des créations et des extensions de
compétences ici la Constitution ne parle
pas de compensation elle parle donc
d'accompagnement à partir du moment où
l'État étant ou créer une compétence
il faut qu'il y ait un accompagnement
financier ceux qui ne veut pas dire une
compensation intégrale
ce sont les ressources nécessaires qui
sont décidées cela a deux significations
première signification ça veut dire
qu'en dehors du cas des transferts des
créations et des extensions la
Constitution ne garantit rien elle ne
garantit pas une compensation elle ne
garantit pas une un accompagnement
financier deuxième signification
ce n'est pas parce que la Constitution
ne le prévoit pas que c'est interdit la
Constitution ne prévoit pas que le
législateur ne doit pas compenser autre
chose que les créations les extensions
ou les transferts mais après tout rien
ne lui interdit de le faire
ça c'était le premier point donc le
cadre normatif deuxième point nous
sommes face à un système sous contrôle
des juges sous contrôle du juge
constitutionnel et sous contrôle du juge
administratif et il faut dire ici que
les juges ont une position que je
qualifierais de de rationnel de
rationnel à l'égard des termes transfert
création extension deux idées première
idée le juge que ça soit le juge
administratif ou le juge constitutionnel
distingue bien d'une part les transferts
et d'autre part les créations et les
extensions va être une extension je cite
toute nouvelle mission rattachable à une
compétence déjà assurée par une
collectivité territoriale c'est un
élargissement d'une compétence existante
la création c'est une compétence
nouvelle dépourvue de liens avec une
compétence déjà exercée donc le juge
fait bien la différence comme la
Constitution entre les deux et un tira
donc les conséquences financières
deuxième distinction qu'aupère bien le
juge il distingue bien les extensions et
les créations de ce qui n'est pas
extension et création c'est à dire que
ce qui est analysé comme étant une
simple modification où on simple ou un
simple aménagement ne sera pas traité
comme une extension ou une création
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une modification
ou un aménagement de compétences je cite
une modification ou une aménagement ne
change pas le périmètre de la compétence
ne change pas son champ ne change pas sa
nature ne change pas sa finalité
conclusion si il y a un aménagement
ou une modification de compétences il ne
bénéficie pas de la garantie
constitutionnelle de compensation mais
je le répète rien n'interdit au
législateur si ça se fait par une voie
légitime à la voie législative de
compenser financièrement troisième et
dernier point les points d'achoppement
parce qu'il faut identifier les points
d'achoppement madame le Président Madame
le Président Monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur vous avez fait
allusion à différents points je
reprendrai trois d'un point de vue
juridique si l'on se place du côté des
collectivités territoriales il y a trois
points qui peuvent poser problème et
dont je présume que vous souhaiteriez
les améliorer premier point on vient de
le dire et vous l'avez dit à partir du
moment où l'action de la loi
de l'exécutif se traduit par une simple
modification où on simple aménagement
d'une compétence et bien il n'y a pas de
compensation financière là-dessus les
textes ne prévoient rien donc peut-être
qu'il y a un travail à faire pour
améliorer les choses ce qui ne veut pas
dire que les choses seraient simples car
il faudrait savoir ce qui est une
modification ce qui est un aménagement
de manière précise mais il y a sans
doute du travail à faire là-dessus
deuxième point pour les transferts de
compétences qui donnent donc lieu à
compensation intégrale la période de
référence qui sert à calculer la somme
qui va constituer la compensation
financière et peut-être problématique je
serai très bref
c'est construit une sorte de
standardisation de la compensation si on
compense quelque chose si c'est une
dépense de fonctionnement c'est trois
ans avec du Fou ces trois ans au moins
trois ans au maximum trois ans ou 3 ans
si on compense de l'investissement c'est
5 ans avec du fou c'est 5 ans si au
maximum 5 ans c'est au minimum 5 ans
pourquoi cette standardisation est-ce
que ça veut dire que tous les transferts
de compétences doivent être analysés
étudiés de la même façon c'est toujours
trois ans ou 5 ans ça je vous avoue que
le juriste ne le comprend pas il
comprend la norme il comprend pas le
pourquoi enfin il le devine troisième
point d'achoppement évidemment vous
l'avez dit l'absence de réexamen
régulier de la compensation c'est à dire
l'absence de l'examen régulier des bases
de la compensation est-ce que
effectivement quelque chose qui a été
transféré en 1983 peut toujours être
compensée financièrement comme salé
depuis 1983 je termine là
ouvrez la réflexion là dessus pose un
problème est-ce que ça veut dire que
l'on peut créer un droit à compensation
et à réévaluation de la compensation de
manière perpétuelle voilà c'était le
cadre juridique je vous remercie
enchaîner et dans l'ordre croissant
on finira par les dames pour l'élégance
du propos
bon désolé pour cette inéligance
c'est bon
c'est bon ouais c'est bon ouais
c'est bon là
alors madame la Présidente je suis
président madame la rapporteur mesdames
dessinatrice messieurs dessinateur
moi je suis un vieux maire je suis maire
depuis le siècle dernier
et c'est pas une question qu'on se pose
depuis aujourd'hui ça fait 25 ans que
j'entends à peu près la même réflexion
et dans la présentation de cette table
ronde je trouvais sur un rapport qui
avait été faussé là qui date de 2010
c'est-à-dire depuis 13 ans il s'appelait
il a été fait par Yves crettinger et
Roland
s'appelait les transferts de compétences
pistes pour des relations apaisées entre
l'État et les collectivités locales
voilà ce qu'on souhaite c'est avoir ces
relations apaisées mais je crois pas
qu'en lisait encore totalement trouvé
vous avez posé la question
enfin la maxime qui décide paye vous
savez François va rien Marouane
complétait toujours en disant qu'il
décide paye qui paie décide et
dans mes expériences d'élus en tant que
mère d'une petite commune président
d'Interco conseiller régional salut mon
collègue du cancer régional du rhume du
Rhin ou président de des maires de
Côte-d'Or et salut sénateur
c'est une proposition mais je sais que
c'est très très compliqué à mettre en
œuvre mais dans l'absolu on aurait
sûrement besoin au niveau des concentrés
de ce type de commission
pour préparer la table ronde moi j'ai
demandé la vie des 698 mères de Côte
d'Or
je viens à Paris je prends mon train je
vais voir les sénatrice et les sénateurs
qu'est-ce que vous avez à leur dire sur
ce sujet parce qu'il en ressort ce peut
être surprise c'est que les mers ne font
absolument pas confiances en une
compensation juste et pérenne ça c'est
pas du tout une surprise que ce soit
dans le cas d'un transfert de
compétences à la commune au maire et
bien sûr ils ont soulevé le problème des
mécanismes de plus en plus lourd
financièrement ou en termes d'ingénierie
lorsque l'on nous donne une une
compétence et dans l'hypothèse d'une
nouvelle étape de décentralisation
comprend que c'est un vrai frein et donc
dans les retours des mers je vais être
un peu plus maintenant terre à terre je
vais vous donner quelques exemples
qu'ils évoquent en termes de personnel
alors il y a des trucs qui marchent très
bien mais après c'est l'inquiétude
notamment par exemple pour les maisons
France service ça marche bien voilà la
question c'est la compensation dans le
temps pour les formations pour bien sûr
l'évolution des personnels et on sent
bien que là on paie les dégâts
on fait une nouvelle cartographie France
services on peut les dégâts de la
cartographie trésorerie gendarmerie etc
et sur le regard très très prudent qu'on
les élus locaux sur de nouveaux services
qui sont dans un maillage de la même
manière quelque chose qui marche bien
les conseillers numériques les conseils
numériques elle a de la même manière on
pose la question qu'ils sont de
formation
leur la pérennisation de ces postes ou
en fin de compte on fait le boulot de
l'État voilà d'ailleurs petite
parenthèse on se plaint pas parce que
avant qu'il y ait ses conseils
numériques c'était le maire et la
secrétaire de mairie qui d'une manière
un peu empirique faisait ce qu'il
pouvait notamment pour remplir les
déclarations fiscales je me dépêche
autre exemple qu'on me donne ce qu'on
appelle les duistes
le du Myst c'est l'intervenant
d'enseignement musical en école sur le
temps scolaire bah là pas du tout
compensé on pourrait imaginer de quelle
manière on pourrait avoir cette
compensation bien sûr ils m'ont parlé
des compensations fiscales je n'y
reviens pas
c'est peut-être en parler mais je
voulais vous apporter un dernier point
d'actualité
les maires
ce questionne sur le coup
afin d'assurer leur rôle notamment
vis-à-vis de la cybercriminalité vous
avez parlé de 1983
protéger nos données que nous avons dans
nos communes ça n'a pas le même qu'en
1983 voilà c'est vous savez que une
commune de allez 200 à 8 ans elle va
avoir un budget peut-être de 100.000
euros de fonctionnement s'il faut se
doter d'un logiciel plus important d'un
pare-feu etc et ben ça va être un coup
de 1000 euros et 1000 euros 1% du budget
qui n'est pas compensé et donc c'est
c'est vraiment cette question de
nouvelles manières de regarder des
compensations dans un contexte qui est
complètement différent
on va parler aussi de la question de
l'urbanisme on va passer au PLU bien sûr
il n'y aura plus 4 pi de
l'accompagnement pour les communes qui
est en RNU et qui était un système à une
aide d'ingénierie de la part de l'État
et qui va en fait disparaître et ça dans
le cadre de l'application de la loi
allure je voudrais juste vous remercier
pour votre invitation
bien sûr les 698 mères tous n'ont pas
répondu mais
vous font confiance
pour pouvoir trouver des solutions pour
que nous puissions enfin trouver des
relations apaisées dans le cadre des
compensations je vous remercie
nous avons bien compris que la
délégation collectivité territoriale
avait cette responsabilité
de répondre effectivement
à l'ensemble
très bien merci merci Monsieur le Maire
maintenant nous allons donner la parole
à madame Isabelle Dufour vous intervenez
en qualité de présidente d'une PC merci
c'est la même merci donc mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
Messieurs les élus mesdames messieurs
merci d'ailleurs de l'invitation
moi également j'ai été regarder du côté
de mes collègues élus au niveau de la
communauté de communes du Seigneur que
c'est également au niveau des
représentants de l'Association des mers
ruraux des Landes pour essayer de faire
porter une parole
landaise ou du moins du sud des Landes
auprès de cette assemblée alors avant de
démarrer si tu es un petit peu peut-être
la Communauté de Communes du Seigneur
puisque peut-être ne vous la connaissez
pas donc il s'agit de huit communes dans
le sud des Landes avec 28 000 habitants
sur un territoire une fois et demi celui
de la ville de Paris avec des grandes
diversités puisque nous avons des
communes la plus petite ayant 350
habitants et la plus importante 13000
habitants
c'est un territoire particulièrement
dynamique puisque nous connaissons une
croissance démographique qui a conduit
un doublement de la population depuis 30
ans et avec un apport d'une population
extérieure vieillissante on est ce que
l'on dit un territoire attractif et bien
sûr ça pose un certain nombre de
questions et de problèmes puisque vous
avez eu les échos du sud de du
territoire la pression sur le logement
et le coût social de la dépendance est
extrêmement important donc c'est un
territoire qui tire son dynamisme
également d'un développement économique
important avec 8600 emplois et puis un
défleurant tel que Safran hélicoptère
engine par exemple avec 1500 agents sur
le territoire de Tarnos et puis des
entreprises industrielles sur le port de
Tarnos je fais ce petit détour parce que
vous verrez que dans la suite du de la
de la prise de parole ça a son
importance voilà et donc nous nous
posons effectivement un certain nombre
de au niveau des élus de la communauté
de communes sur les services aux
personnes aux entreprises qu'il faut que
nous développions les politiques
publiques locales
issues des compétences que l'État
régalien a soit transféré soit imposées
par la loi au bloc communal et plus
spécifiquement aux OPC comme les nôtres
nécessitent bien évidemment de
nombreuses ressources il s'agit comme le
titre de nos échanges de précisent que
l'état donne aux collectivités les
moyens de faire face à ce qu'il impose
en matière de règles de normes et de
transfert et ce de façon pérenne ça déjà
été évoqué j'insiste sur ce terme de
pérennité donc je vais prendre pour ma
part trois exemples et je vais relayer
une inquiétude le premier exemple tout
d'abord c'est les sources de financement
que l'État mobilise pour accompagner les
initiatives du bloc communal alors je
vais les citer pêle-mêle la décile la
DETR le CRPE le fond vert les fonds
mobilité active et bien sûr points de
suspension
ici plusieurs observations la première
c'est
l'ingénierie donc il faut disposer pour
monter ces demandes de dossier d'aide
auprès des services de l'État et pour
pouvoir pouvoir en bénéficier bien
évidemment
l'ingénierie dans évidemment les
communes rurales ne disposent pas ou
plus et elles sont donc profondément
pénalisées au niveau de l'accès à ces
demandes d'aide d'autant plus que les
services de l'État en département en
préfecture en sous-préfecture sont en
sous-effectif et donc c'est très
compliqué à ce niveau là d'accompagner
les élus locaux deuxième observation les
demandes de subvention doivent souvent
répondre à des appels à projets ciblés
qui ne correspondent pas toujours aux
besoins réels et immédiats des
collectivités locales
enfin une autre observation tient à
souligner la différence entre le
discours et les actes de la part de
l'État prenez le CRPE le contrat donc de
relance et de transition écologique la
bonne idée était d'abonder les aides
locales donc la DETR et la décile afin
de valoriser les projets du bloc
communal qui s'inscrivent dans la
thématique de la transition écologique
et nous nous sommes tous prêtés au jeu
en élaborant des diagnostics en montant
défis action en priorisant les actions à
mettre en oeuvre et au final que
constatons nous que les services de
l'État se servent du CRPE pour en faire
un critère discriminatoire des projets
car les fonds supplémentaires sont
absents il faut donc écrémé et un projet
qui n'est pas labellisé certes à très
peu de chances d'obtenir de la dotr et
de la des cils actuellement
on notera en autora d'ailleurs que dans
mon département les Landes la préfecture
refuse de cumuler DETR et des cils par
manque de crédit alors que ce cumul est
autorisé et serait largement nécessaire
et pour notre communauté de communes
cela représente 830 000 euros de DETR et
436000 euros de décès je vous laisse
faire les commentaires dans vos têtes
l'exemple numéro 2
concerne la question des déchets c'est
bien un domaine dans lequel la question
de la sobriété énergétique où tous les
Français se retrouvent sur la nécessité
d'atteindre des objectifs de réduction
et de valorisation pour autant et comme
souvent sous le couvert d'idées qui se
veulent vertueuse l'État impose des
règles rarement d'ailleurs de façon
partagée ce qui est d'ailleurs un autre
problème sans en mesurer correctement
les conséquences pour les structures
impactées par exemple il s'agit
d'imposer plus de tri d'augmenter
régulièrement la TGA P d'imposer une
augmentation de la valorisation des
déchets tout cela bien sûr génère des
augmentations du coût du service rendu
et dans le même temps
l'état plafonne le prix de rachat de
l'électricité des unités de valorisation
énergétique qui incinèrent les déchets à
180 euros par kilowatt
il prive ainsi les structures de
ressources supplémentaires et impose
d'augmenter le financement de qui des
EPCI à titre d'exemple mon EPCI subit
une augmentation de sa participation au
syndicat de collecte et du traitement
des déchets de 18% en 2023 ce poste est
passé de 4 millions à 4 millions 7 qui
représentent près de 20% de notre budget
général et cela valait en augmentant
avec notamment la mise en place de
nouvelles exigences et notamment le tri
des bio déchets à compter du 1er janvier
2024 alors je sais que de nombreux est
possible feront le choix d'augmenter le
taux de la Tom pour absorber ses
dépenses mais cela devient insupportable
pour le contribuable qui voit ses
prélèvements fiscaux augmentés quel que
soit sa situation d'ailleurs car on sait
que l'atome est calculée sur la valeur
locative cadastrale et qu'elle ne dépend
pas du volume d'ordures produit par le
foyer ce qui est donc parfaitement
injuste et je précise d'ailleurs que ce
n'est pas ce qu'a fait la Communauté de
Communes du Seignanx
troisième exemple le développement
économique effectivement été évoqué
précédemment en effet si au niveau
national que les orientations en matière
de politique de l'emploi sont décidés
pas moins que le travail dans le domaine
du maintien et de l'accueil des
entreprises s'opère au plus près du
terrain avec notamment les régions et
les EPCI qui en ont la compétence
obligatoire et là aussi l'état qui a
souhaité diminuer les impôts de
production a décidé
à nouveau sans concertation de supprimer
en deux ans la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises
et de la compenser
auprès des collectivités par une
dotation
issue de la TVA est calculée sur la
moyenne des 4 dernières années de 2020 à
2023 ce système est profondément injuste
car pour un rappel nous avons subi une
pandémie pendant deux ans qui a impacté
le résultat des entreprises dans les
montants des CAE de des années 2020 et
2021 pour notre territoire la CVAE
représente un million 7 par an soit 6%
de nos recettes de plus ce mode de
calcul pénalise les territoires les plus
dynamiques comme le nôtre puisque nous
avons sur notre territoire de nombreuses
zones d'activités économiques en pleine
expansion et nous le constatons nous
accueillons des entreprises qui nous
sollicitent de plus en plus quand et
pour que nous développons légitimement
de nombreux services j'en veux pour
preuve safran ingénierie hélicoptère et
l'ingénierie dont j'avais parlé au tout
début de votre de mon intervention avec
un restaurant inter-entreprise la
Communauté de Communes va devoir
investir quelques 10 millions d'euros
alors bien sûr il y aura des aides de
l'État de la Région du Département mais
pour nos fonds propres c'est 2 à 3
millions d'euros et cet exemple là et
bien sûr suivi par de nombreuses
demandes pour d'autres services par les
entreprises de nos zones et nous ne
cessons de le répéter ça a été dit redit
qu'en penser à l'euro à l'instant T sans
revaloration revalorisation annuelle et
préjudiciable sur la durée et pénalisera
donc un territoire comme le nôtre qui se
veut un territoire dynamique donc la
question qui est à se poser finalement
en déconnectant les recettes économiques
des territoires cela ne risque-t-il pas
de freiner fortement les investissements
des collectivités dans ce domaine
je voudrais profiter également de
l'occasion qui m'est donnée pour évoquer
une question qui nous inquiète la
question de la dépendance qui est une
grande cause nationale et dans le
financement repose pour partie
importante sur les collectivités
peut-être cela sera-t-il repris par la
représentante de départements national
nous sommes ici devant un défi d'ampleur
tente sur le plan de l'organisation des
services que sur la question des
personnels mais également sur le
financement de cette dépendance nous
sommes confrontés à une difficulté de
recrutement sans précédent des agents à
domicile pour faire face à des besoins
grandissants des personnes âgées qui
souhaitent rester à domicile c'est
vraiment un sujet de préoccupation
majeure que nous partageons avec les
conseils départementaux et dans ce
domaine comme dans d'autres nous sommes
confrontés à de nouvelles exigences
imposées par l'État sans concertation
j'en veux pour preuve la nouvelle
demande de fusion des services d'aide à
domicile avec les services infirmiers à
domicile
qui auront des conséquences
organisationnelles et financières
indéniable dans les mois à venir voilà
je voudrais terminer mon propos
rapidement puisque nous avions 10
minutes pour dire que à notre niveau le
budget de mon OPCI dépend des
compensations dotation de l'État bien
sûr et ce à hauteur de 53% de nos
recettes sur un fonctionnement de 29,3
millions d'euros c'est donc 15,5
millions d'euros donc donné par l'État
pour compensation et dotation vous
comprendrez bien que dans de telles
circonstances il y avait les
observations faites à partir des
exemples choisis que la proposition
d'une loi pour garantir l'autonomie
financière des collectivités
territoriales
garantissant la compensation financière
des transferts de compétences dans le
temps et proposant un examen régulier
des ressources des collectivités
territoriales comme d'ailleurs le
propose quelques sénateurs ici je crois
autour de la table je crois avoir
compris je propose que effectivement
cette loi soit proposée et elle est de
plus en plus nécessaire si on te les
cales observation que nous formulons du
loin de la communauté de communes du
Seigneur que je vous remercie pour votre
invitation votre écoute et j'espère
votre compréhension
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente nous
avons bien compris nous avons bien saisi
tous les messages effectivement
maintenant je vais donner la parole à
Madame Sophie pantin cher Sophie qui
interviendra donc en qualité de
président du département de la Lozère
merci Guylaine madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et mes chers collègues donc je
voulais d'abord aussi vous remercier de
me faire de me permettre de m'exprimer
avec vous ce matin sur un sujet comme la
rappeler le collègue mère qui n'est pas
nouveau et moi il y a longtemps que je
dis qui commande paye voilà c'est en
tout cas c'est comme ça que que ça
s'applique pour le département de la
Lozère et pour nos satellites en
particulier voilà je trouve que en tout
cas l'enjeu que vous avez repéré sur la
question de nos capacités budgétaires et
essentielles parce que comme la rappeler
madame la Présidente c'est ce qui nous
permet de pouvoir déployer nos
propositions et nos politiques publiques
sur le terrain au profit de nos
concitoyens et aujourd'hui vous savez
que nos territoires moi donc c'est un
territoire hyper rural
le rôle du département est vraiment une
strate qui permet à la fois cette
proximité cette capacité d'agir et de
pouvoir porter des projets et
structurants et à chaque fois qu'on a
moins de moyens c'est moins de politique
et ça vient alimenter un espèce de
sentiment d'abandon sur nos territoires
et qui petit à petit conduisent à faire
le terreau de de certaines oppositions
extremistes donc ce que je voulais aussi
rappeler peut-être une différence avec
certains autres territoires c'est que
chez nous la commande publique est
essentielle en terme d'investissement et
que peut-être plus qu'ailleurs on est
sollicité sur sur des politiques qui
sont dit optionnelles ou partagées parce
que justement
nos communes et nos communautés de
communes on peut de capacité
contributives et donc on se tourne
peut-être un peu plus facilement vers le
département donc vous savez que les
départements
ces dernières années ont quand même
largement contribué aussi
à amortir la crise sanitaire à partir de
mesures gouvernementales qui ont été
décidées alors c'est vrai que le
résultat est peut-être moins mauvais que
ce que on avait pu imaginer un moment
donné mais c'est essentiellement dû à la
dynamique des DMTO sur lequel en fait on
a on a pas de garantie dans l'avenir et
donc il faut être extrêmement prudent
sur l'effet ciseaux en fait que certains
de mes collègues subissent déjà puisque
nous sommes l'échelons locales qui est
le plus exposé à la fois parce que nous
n'avons plus aucune autonomie financière
vous savez que toutes nos recettes en
fait viennent de l'État donc cbae TVA on
a les DMTO mais comme nos dépenses qui
sont majoritairement sociales en tout
cas par exemple nous sur notre budget
c'est plus de la moitié notre budget et
nos dépenses qui sont par nature pro
cyclique et sur lequel en fait parfois
on n'a pas de décision à prendre lorsque
vous avez une personne âgée qui a un
plan APA Vous devez le mettre en place
lorsque vous avez quelqu'un qui quitte
l'indemnisation chômage vous devez payer
le RSA donc de fait ça s'impose à nous
je vais juste vous prendre l'exemple du
budget de la Lozère 110 millions en
fonctionnement 50 millions
d'investissements donc vous voyez un peu
la faiblesse en volume même si
proportionnellement nous sommes plutôt
pas mauvais et quatrième département à
investir en fait sur ces 160 millions il
n'y a que 15 millions sur lequel en fait
nous pouvons réellement décider de la
destination de ses fonds c'est je pense
que ça suffit à tout explication donc
vous savez que nous avons perdu la part
du du foncier
bâti que nous n'avons donc plus aucun
levier fiscal et pourtant quand le pays
va mal c'est bien la strate
départementale qui est en première ligne
et qui doit amortir avec ses politiques
sociales donc c'est quand même assez
paradoxal et on a certains collègues qui
n'investissent plus donc je rejoins ce
qu'a dit la collègue représentant des
communautés de communes donc c'est moins
de commandes publiques pour nos
entreprises et pour l'économie
dans les mois qui arrivent donc alors
peut-être pour pas être trop redondante
il y a peut-être quand même trois
catégories il y a les transferts qui
disent pas leur nom sur lequel je
voulais dire quelques mots ceux qui sont
soi-disant compensés à leur prêt et puis
la question des compétences nouvelles
donc si je vais sur les transferts qui
disent pas leur nom par exemple
typiquement la réforme du chômage dans
les semaines qui arrivent on est déjà en
train de voir l'impact mais on va
pouvoir mesurer chacun ce que ce que ça
va coûter la question de l'impact du
changement climatique même s'il est à va
intervenir sur sur des co-financement
aujourd'hui que ce soit pour nos 10 je
suis présidente aussi de Mons 10 quand
on voit le niveau de la TSCA c'est à
dire l'aumône que l'on nous donne au
niveau des 10 parce qu'on peut pas dire
autre chose moi sur un budget de 8,5
millions j'ai 1,7 millions de TSCA voilà
donc aujourd'hui l'impact du changement
climatique c'est bien nous qui devons en
fait investir pour y faire face les
réservoirs d'eau que nous sommes en
train de faire ou les soutiens que l'on
apporte aux communes pour répondre à ces
enjeux-là c'est bien nous aussi dans le
même type de décision en fait de
transfert qui ne disent pas leur nom
c'est aussi par exemple la fin de la
tézette quand l'ingénierie que l'on
avait sur les routes donc tous les
départements ont mis en place de
l'ingénierie départementale et
aujourd'hui je sais pas si vous avez vu
les dernières annonces on nous annonce
qu'une structure départementale
nationale va remettre en place de
l'ingénierie au lieu au lieu de venir
accompagner finalement chacun des
départements et devenir nous aider nous
dans notre ingénierie voilà donc on va
remonter des usines à gaz il va falloir
recréer des commissions pour faire de la
coordination enfin tout ça c'est du coup
humain de la perte de temps
donc ça ce sont tous les transferts qui
disent pas leur nom mais qui coûte sur
les transferts opérés à l'Europe notre
sénatrice guylan Pantel a parlé des
routes et des collèges dans son
introduction
moi j'ai regardé simplement les chiffres
là sur pour la Lozère donc sur les
routes et les collèges sur la part de
TSA donc j'ai bien enlevé la part du 10
entre 2005 et 2010 c'est 11 millions en
fait sur les routes sur la même période
le coût RH ça a été 30 millions sur les
collèges 12 millions vous voyez je suis
à 42 en m'a donné 11 millions et là ce
sont quand même les années je suis qu'en
2010 donc je ne compte pas ni les
charges de fonctionnement je compte pas
les PPI sur l'investissement je compte
pas toutes les nouvelles normes sur sur
l'isolation sur le radon sur je ne sais
quoi enfin surtout tout ce que on doit
mettre en place sur les is donc vous
l'avez dit aussi donc les allocations
individuelles de solidarité nous la
Lozère alors c'est pas le RSA qui est la
première dépense puisqu'on est un avec
une population âgée et c'est bien la PH
chez nous qui qui pèse le plus ou on est
à presque 11 millions donc globalement
j'ai 22,7 millions sur les is et j'ai un
reste à charge de 7 millions 7 millions
chaque année donc vous pouvez remultiver
avec certains collègues on avait envie
en fait de mettre une espèce de panneau
sur chacun de nos hôtels
des départements et de marquer l'état
nos doigts voilà et puis chaque jour de
faire circuler les sommes d'argent mais
peut-être que il y aurait une prise de
conscience parce que ce sont des
millions et des millions d'euros voilà
donc voilà pour pour ces éléments là et
puis on a évidemment tout ce qui est
compétences dites nouvelles du moustique
tigre à plein d'autres choses sur lequel
on nous demande de travailler ou
d'énormes qui engendrent des coûts et
vous savez quand on nous transfère comme
ça des compétences nouvelles ou
après on nous reproche finalement
finalement d'embaucher parce qu'il faut
quand même les mettre en oeuvre ses
compétences et donc après on nous dit
les collectivités ont embauché voilà
donc là c'est un peu le double langage
quand à la DGF j'ai aussi regardé à quel
niveau on en était aujourd'hui donc 2000
alors c'est les chiffres de 2022 DGF je
suis au même niveau que de l'année 2006
voilà vous imaginez tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis et qui n'est donc pas
couvert quand on a une compensation
on nous enlève la dynamique de la taxe
ça a été le cas sur sur la TVA voilà et
puis quand on regarde plus finement
parce qu'en fait sur le papier on
pourrait avoir parfois se dire
finalement c'est c'est compenser quand
vous regardez les critères pour
compenser et là je rejoins ce qui a été
dit sur l'investissement quand on prend
les trois dernières années que les temps
n'a rien fait forcément la compensation
elle est pas très importante et puis il
y a une autre critère chez nous qui nous
pénalise énormément si le critère
population vous regarderez il y a à
chaque fois et pour c'est à dire qu'on
ne prend jamais en compte la variable
territoire dans ce pays il va falloir
quand même un jour qu'on ait une
véritable politique d'aménagement
surtout à une période où devant nous on
a le changement climatique on aura des
mobilités de population qui vont
s'imposer forcément y compris sur le
territoire national il faut pas penser
que c'est au bout du monde donc voilà je
pense qu'il faudrait que l'on puisse
sortir en fait de ça et prendre en
compte aussi les effets de seuil vous
avez enfin moi dans mon département j'ai
un DGS comme tous les pro département il
me coûte aussi cher que les pro
département voilà et pour autant
derrière j'ai 700 agents au lieu d'en
avoir peut-être 3000 5000 à gérer donc
il y a toute une série comme ça de
défait de seuil qui sont pas pris en
compte
un mot sur la méthode
moi ça fait 23 ans 24 ans je suis élu
j'ai été maire j'ai été à la région
département depuis 2004 voilà enfin
d'autres mandat ce qui m'a toujours
choqué et alors particulièrement avec ce
gouvernement mais pas que
c'est la logique non concertée est
toujours unilatérale en fait qui qui
prévaut et finalement qui déguise un
certain nombre de décisions et d'une
manière générale on ne fait pas
confiance au territoire et on ne fait
pas confiance aux élus locaux voilà et
tant que ça ça changera pas et qu'on
nous regardera comme des contre-pouvoirs
et qu'on cherchera finalement à mettre
un mal tous les corps intermédiaires ce
pays ne pourra pas aller bien voilà
enfin bon après c'est mon opinion
personnelle et je pense que il y a aussi
un certain nombre de décisions si on
nous faisait confiance qui pourrait être
géré différemment et qui sont
insuffisamment préparés il y a vraiment
un déficit en fait d'évaluation au
départ sur des textes alors bon on a
tous subi les décisions
à matière de RH je vais pas revenir
là-dessus je vais essayer juste aller
sur sur le social vous avez parlé en
fait des sables et desiades donc qui
vont fusionner oui qui vont entraîner
d'abord des difficultés parce qu'on est
en train sur le terrain d'opposer en
fait des associations parce que nous on
est obligé de gérer ça on nous demande
des agréments supplémentaires donc
qu'est-ce qui va se passer il va y avoir
des transferts de personnels de salariés
alors qu'on a déjà des problématiques
d'attractivité pour recruter et surtout
par exemple l'avenant 43 sur les
services d'aide à domicile une
illisibilité totale des dispositifs on
nous avait annoncé 70%. on est tombé à
50% donc 2022 nous les a payés 50% 2023
on verra ce qu'on aura mais on voit bien
que entre les effets d'annonce et ce qui
arrive c'est compliqué
le Ségur de la même manière il y a eu
des annonces comme ça que ce soit le la
Forcade ou plastex qui ont été faites un
peu rapidement on a les oubliés du Ségur
parce que nous on a pris la pression sur
le terrain par les établissements par le
secteur de la de l'enfance voilà alors
que si on avait pu en discuter au départ
on serait pas là et je vous prends le
dernier exemple la réforme des
assistants familiaux je sais pas si vous
l'avez suivi mais là c'est pareil un
décret d'application 31 août 2022 pour
une mise en oeuvre 1er septembre 2022
donc vous voyez dans la nuit il a fallu
carburer moi je le dis de manière un peu
ironique
donc réforme des assistants familiaux si
vous avez un enfant le premier
ils sont passés à 151
SMIC horaire et ensuite 70 SMIC pour le
deuxième et troisième enfant donc c'est
le jackpot si on avait interrogé ne
serait-ce que deux trois départements on
aurait tous dit attention parce
qu'aujourd'hui je peux vous dire ce qui
se passe sur le terrain moi je suis en
Lozère les assistants familiaux on a
beaucoup de mal pour les recruter ils
vont prendre un enfant en Lozère ils
vont prendre un enfant en Aveyron ils
vont prendre un enfant dans l'Hérault
c'est jackpot financièrement
et nous par contre on va manquer de
place pour confier nos enfants voilà
tout ça parce qu'on n'a pas prévu les
garde-fous sur sur cette loi taquée qui
qui au fond était là aussi et à juste
titre pour revaloriser ses salaires
voilà chez nous sur les dix plus haut
salaire vous savez que l'on doit publier
j'ai 6 assistants familles au même voilà
oui je pense donc de la même manière sur
la loi ASV la revalorisation de la CTP
la loi menée on a eu droit à la même
chose donc d'une manière générale en
fait on n'est pas associé à un amont on
subit en plus les attaques des
départements et pour conclure on a
également c'est soi-disant
contractualisation
qu'on essaye de nous vendre alors on est
convoqué chez les préfets on nous dit
qu'il faut contractualiser etc donc
quand vous avez un préfet intelligent ou
une préfète intelligente qui vous permet
d'afficher des politiques que vous
mettez déjà en œuvre finalement vous
arrivez à avoir
ressources supplémentaires pour faire ce
que vous faites sur sur le terrain mais
sinon en fait ça engendre finalement il
faut des nouvelles actions qui sont bien
sûr limitées dans le temps donc couilles
d'après quand vous avez mis des
opérateurs sur le terrain ils reviennent
vous voir une fois que vous avez plus
l'argent au bout des trois ans de la
contractualisation voilà et ça engendre
en fait des dépenses nouvelles et
parfois pire que ça c'est que en fait on
va se détourner de des besoins réels du
territoire pour aller capter trois
francs 6 ou voilà donc c'est vrai que
Ghislaine qui siège dans l'assemblée
départementale le C on a contractualisé
pour le le plat en pauvreté tous les
autres moi j'ai refusé parce qu'on passe
notre temps soit aller sur voilà sur des
actions qui ne correspondent pas
réellement à nos besoins de nos publics
on s'occupe plus de nos publics et on
passe notre temps à démultiplier des
réunions de coordination il faut rendre
des comptes et on nous transforme en
auxiliaire c'est à dire que cet état
depuis 2015 moi j'ai l'impression qu'il
prend les départements pour des agences
de l'État et des auxiliaires voilà et je
pourrais démultiplier sur les clauses de
revoyure même quand on en a bon c'est
compliqué l'éclairca on pourrait on
pourrait en parler voilà moi je pense
que en fait toutes ces questions elles
sont fondamentales et j'espère vraiment
que votre assemblée va pouvoir faire
bouger les lignes ça pose une véritable
question de l'efficacité de l'action
publique parce qu'aujourd'hui on en a un
point moi des fois je dis aux collègues
mais franchement mettons des
fonctionnaires parce que finalement
qu'est-ce qu'on décide enfin on est
quand même très loin de du projet
politique que nous avons porté et on
passe un temps fou à essayer de se
sécuriser juridiquement
parce que avec toutes ces normes toutes
ces obligations
on passe beaucoup plus de temps
finalement à ça plutôt que qu'à
développer des nouvelles actions donc
voilà l'évaluation ça c'est sûr qu'il en
faudrait et travailler autrement et pas
une fois que tout est ficelier est fini
quand c'est descendant le respecter
enfin la libre administration des
collectivités retrouver de l'autonomie
dans nos ressources c'est le pendant en
fait de la libre administration des
collectivités c'est sinon ça a pas de
sens voilà et alors oui à tout texte
toute décision qui qui irait vers le qui
décide
paye voilà et puis
j'avais lu donc dans un de une de vos
propositions c'était aussi donc
d'interdire tout des prêts s'il n'y
avait pas une décision législative au
départ nous concernant voilà donc je
suis prête à répondre à vos questions et
il y a certains sujets sur lequel je
suis passé très vite parce que soit ça a
été abordé et puis c'était pour tenir
les 10 minutes aussi merci
merci madame la Présidente merci Sophie
et bien nous allons entendre pour pour
terminer ces auditions en fait les
premières les premiers moments Monsieur
Philippe vahider délégué général au sein
des régions de France et merci
même la rapporteur madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame et
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs la
question que que
nous intéressons ce matin avec une
question centrale en matière de liberté
locale je rentre toujours la Réunion
j'accompagnais la présidente Delga à
l'invitation de Huguette Bello la
Présidente de la Région Réunion pour
célébrer sur place les 40 ans de la
Région Réunion puisque les conseillers
régionaux d'outre-mer ont été élus en
1983 ils étaient après ceux de la Corse
les premiers conseillers régionaux élus
de métropole ne l'ont été qu'en 1986
trois ans plus tard les anniversaires
sont des occasions de fait sont aussi
des occasions de bilarant le bilan
évidemment des de la Région Réunion et
considérable comme les le bilan des
collectivités en matière d'actions et
s'estompiles faut se réjouir mais ces
libertés locales sont des libertés qui
ne se traduisent pas seulement à travers
ce qui est construit ou à travers les
compétences qui sont transférées elles
se elles s'évalue aussi à travers la
capacité à les exercer ce que l'on
appelle ce que
on appelle dans la Constitution libre
administration cette capacité les
exercer elle est à la fois technique
juridique et budgétaire c'est bien
l'objet de nos échanges de nos échanges
ce matin force de constater que cette
liberté
à s'administrer
elle est à la fois contrôlée parfois
empêcher et en tout cas
comme les précédents intervenants ont eu
l'occasion de le mentionner elle ne
permet pas le plein d'exercice et de la
démocratie de proximité la liberté
locale c'est-à-dire la mise en oeuvre
par des élus
de leur de leurs projets avec la
responsabilité que cela que cela appelle
avant d'entrer dans les exemples puisque
c'est l'objet de
cette partie
je revenir sur très brièvement les
finances des régions
les finances des régions en 2022 ont
bien évident que le bloc régional qui
est un bloc évidemment de
d'investissement de construction
les régions sont les seules
collectivités à ne pas avoir reconstitué
leur épargne Davant crise
c'est une situation qui
est singulière c'est une situation qui
découle évidemment de la crise mais
aussi de l'impact d'un certain nombre de
décisions même temps de décision de
l'État en même temps que de l'effort
produit par les régions pour accompagner
les plans de relance de l'État c'est un
effort qui s'inscrit dans leur dans leur
rôle mais qui ne peut prendre toute sa
puissance que dès lors que
elles peuvent gérer pleinement leur
ressources 2023 sera une année complexe
une année de plein d'impact de
l'ensemble des hausses de l'inflation de
2000 de 2022 et cette situation à la
fois de difficultés post crise et
d'incertitude sur le pilotage des
recettes tombe au pire moment au moment
où collectivement nos collectivités aux
côtés de l'État ont besoin d'investir IR
pour faire face à l'ensemble des défis
de la transition climatique
des besoins de de mobilité et au fond
des défis de de demain
mon propos tiendra en trois points qui
au fond on recoupe ceux des précédents
intervenants trois situations les
situations d'absence de compensation
les situations où la question de la
juste compensation est posée et puis la
question de la stabilité dans le temps
de la compensation
alors oui
le professeur cabane soulignait à juste
titre que si le cadre du droit
compensation a été posé était clair il
souffrait il d'un grand nombre de
fragilité de vide d'angle d'angle mort
sur l'absence de compensation il s'agit
d'évoquer des
compétences nouvelles des obligations de
faire transférées collectivités sans que
celle-ci n'ait été en rien compensé pour
leur exercice ou bien
s'agissant de décision qui immédiatement
produisent des hausses de dépenses
elles-mêmes tout justifiable sans doute
mais
n'étant pas décidé par les élus des
collectivités concernées
je vais aussi donner trois exemples
lorsque comme directeur général des
services d'une région nous avons déployé
pris en charge la gestion des réseaux
informatiques des lycées nous avons
procédé par un marché à une grande
facteur pour reprendre en charge des
réseaux tous différents les uns des
autres avec qui c'était construits
progressivement avec une immense variété
de de matériel et le travail de départ a
consisté à réaliser un recensement une
mise à niveau et parfois une
reconstruction de de l'organisation
générale des réseaux dans les dans les
lycées et ensuite de nouvelles
procédures pour en assurer la gestion et
le fonctionnement cette compétence est
devenue celle des régions par l'effet la
loi payant de 2013 sur la refondation de
l'école sans que elle n'était compensée
du moindre centime ni du moindre
transfert de personnel pour pour l'ex
ercer
évidemment vous le savez l'ensemble des
décisions liées à des revalorisations
qu'il s'agisse du point d'indice qui
produit sur le budget des régions une
hausse de 120 millions d'euros en année
pleines en 2000 en 2023 comme celle de
l'augmentation des des bourses
des étudiants ne sont pas décidés par
les régions et produisent des effets par
des effets évidemment sur l'exercice
annuel enfin pour vous donner un exemple
qui date d'hier
blindé des ministres celui en charge de
la famille à clos un rang de
concertation passionnant important lié
au service la mise en oeuvre du service
public de la petite enfance sujet qui
est un enjeu à la fois d'égalité
homme-femme de société du plein emploi
et de lutte contre toutes les formes de
déterminisme géographique sociaux etc le
la pénurie des professionnels existent
aujourd'hui elle va aller croissante
dans ce domaine comme comme dans
quantité d'autres et évidemment les
communes sont en première ligne sur sur
ces sujets parmi les propositions de
nature législative qui était proposé
sans concertation sur sur ce point là
figurer celle de
transcrire un article du code de la
santé l'article l4383-2 qui donne
compétences au ministre de la Santé pour
fixer le nombre des étudiants admis en
première année des formations sanitaires
par exemple des infirmiers les
informations sanitaire sont de la
compétence des régions évidemment et
bien la proposition consistait à
traduire cette disposition dans un
nouvel article
l214-7 du code de l'action sociale et
des familles qui donnerait au ministre
en charge de la famille la compétence
pour fixer tous les ans le nombre des
étudiants admis dans l'ensemble des
formations sanitaires et sociales
correspondant aux métiers de l'accueil
de la petite enfance evidemment cette
idée
n'est pas acceptable sur la forme ni
concerter et constituant à nouveau une
mise sous contrôle de la
décentralisation mais elle ne résoudra
rien sur sur le fond et évidemment nous
privilégions à ce type de disposition
toute forme possible de concertation de
partenariats dans lequel avec l'État
chacun prend en charge une part de
l'effort pour augmenter évidemment le
nombre des personnes formées mais
évidemment
cette voie est sans doute la plus
directe entre l'État et l'entrée
l'entrée en formation évidemment cette
disposition n'étant accompagnée puisque
c'est l'objet de notre échange d'aucune
sorte de compensation
il y a après la question de l'absence de
compensation celle de la de la juste
compensation et mon propos tiendra en
deux parties d'abord la question de
l'évaluation au départ et celle de de
l'impact de la dynamique les régions
sont concernées depuis le 1er janvier
par le transfert de la gestion du fait
adhère comme celle de la gestion des
zones Natura 2000 pour ce qui concerne
les zones Natura 2000 aucun agent n'a
été n'a été transféré de sorte que la
compétence sera intégralement à
reconstruire mais les régions ont très
fortement contesté l'évaluation qui
avait été conduite à la fois des besoins
pour la gestion de du fait Ader comme
ceux des compétences Natura 2000 et
quand bien même nous serions tombés
d'accord
sur l'évaluation des personnels de
l'État gérant c'est ces compétences
quand bien même nous serions tombés
d'accord le principe veut que le
transfert s'effectue accompagné d'un
calcul de coûts en pied de corps
c'est-à-dire correspondant
à de jeunes agents dans leur première
année suivant le recrutement et pas du
tout dans la réalité de des agents qui
exercent la compétence et qui très
logiquement sont à tous les stades de de
leurs carrière il y a donc une question
d'évaluation
de départ et puis il y a évidemment une
question de dynamique sur sur la durée
qui peut se poser dès le départ vous
vous situiez un exemple tout à l'heure
je je peux le reprendre d'une manière
différente celui de la proposition de
transfert des du réseau routier de
l'état non concédé aux collectivités
seuls trois régions se apporter
candidate pour une expérimentation et
évidemment
lorsque l'évaluation des charges est
réalisée sur trois ans ou 5 ans en
fonction du fonctionnement de
l'investissement dans une période telle
que nous la connaissons aujourd'hui
d'une inflation galopante de taux
d'intérêt qui dépasse désormais les les
3% et évidemment d'un réseau dans lequel
les investissements n'ont pas été au
niveau il est tout à fait évident que
dans les années qui viennent les besoins
tentent en fonctionnement qu'en
investissement et dès le départ ne
correspondront pas aux charges
transférées qui sont des charges au
regard du passé dans le passé avec une
inflation qui était stable dans le passé
avec des taux d'intérêt qui étaient
négatifs demain le financement des
investissements rendus nécessaires par
l'état de notre réseau routier ne seront
pas couverts par les transferts de
l'État
enfin un exemple qui est un exemple
comment dire très très mince
j'ai été
moi-même militaire dans un temps qui
n'est pas si qui n'est pas si loin de
hein et nous discutons en ce moment le
la question du transfert de
des modalités de la prise en charge de
la réduction pour les militaires et
leurs familles des billets de train
c'est un c'est un sujet qui est un tout
petit sujet qui jusqu'à présent fait
l'objet de convention avec
entre chacune des administrations et et
avec
chacune des autorités et désormais
prendra la forme d'un décret
c'est-à-dire d'une d'un transfert de
compétences
et bien le principe étant que dans le
cadre d'un endroit à compensation
celui-ci est fixe quelle que soit
l'évolution demain du nombre des
militaires et de leur famille dont je
souhaite qu'il soit à la hausse
évidemment quel que soit demain
l'évolution du nombre de recours et donc
de l'impact pour les autorités
organisatrices des mobilités le montant
de la compétition sera le même
et puis enfin il y a ce que vous
connaissez bien la question de la
stabilité dans le temps l'absence de
compensation est une chose la juste
compensation est évidemment
indispensable la stabilité dans le temps
elle elle conditionne la confiance
cette stabilité dans le temps vous le
savez ici mieux qu'ailleurs elle elle
n'est jamais garantie entre 2013 et 2017
la DGF des régions a baissé de 1
milliard et demi la dessert TP et la
dtce qui qui
venait financer des compétences
transférées et qui constitue des
variables d'ajustement je cite pour la
gestion du budget l'État ont baissé de
315 millions entre 2017 et 2022 au
moment où les régions devenaient
pleinement compétentes pour
les questions de développement
économique la suppression du Fonds de
développement économique en 2018
entraînait une baisse de 450 millions
d'euros de financement et
ces exemples pourraient être multipliés
à l'envie avec la suppression de la
CVAE nous avons tous redécouvert dans
l'immense complexité des finances
locales qu'une fraction des frais de
gestion de la CVAE venez financer la
compétence formation des régions et qui
sont la persévérance
du Sénat et bien aurait conduit à une
baisse de près de 110 millions d'euros
des recettes des régions au en loi de
finances 2000-2023 pour le financement
de la formation professionnelle cette
question de la stabilité je le disais
elle elle
est un élément déterminant de la
confiance à la fois de la confiance
évidemment dans les relations entre les
collectivités et l'État mais aussi dans
la confiance dans la capacité à exercer
pleinement les missions c'est à dire en
particulier à investir
le Sénat dans dans ce rapport sur
l'impact des décisions de l'État sur les
finances locales mettez en évidence un
coup entre 2019 et 2021 je crois de 2
milliards d'euros et formulaire
l'ensemble de propositions qui qui
toutes permettraient en tout cas de
contraindre et en tout cas d'entretenir
ou de recréer un cadre de confiance le
rôle de la CCEC gagnerait à être
renforcé c'est une instance qui
aujourd'hui peut-être contournée
au moment du
de la recentralisation de la compétence
en matière d'apprentissage
la CCEC est à s'était engagé à réunir la
CCEC ça n'a pas été le cas et l'autre
finance a défini l'impact de manière
unilatérale
sur les budgets des collectivités et un
certain nombre de ces
avis aujourd'hui consultatifs pourraient
dans un certain nombre de conditions
être renforcés puis au cœur de ces
sujets figurent la question de
l'évaluation et en particulier la
question de l'évaluation préalable de
l'impact pour les collectivités dans
certains nombre de décisions de l'État
lorsqu'en particulier ces décisions
interviennent dans le champ de
compétences
décentralisé et lorsque en particulier
c'est décisions
produisent des effets sur l'exercice
budgétaire en cours pour lequel le
budget déjà voté ne prévoit pas
d'absorber des hausses de façon de façon
immédiate et puis enfin et pour clore
le Comité des finances locales
gagneraient avoir également son rôle
renforcé lorsque de la même façon
des dispositions sont créatrices
dépenses pour les collectivités dans le
périmètre de leur de leurs compétences
et
à accroître l'obligation d'évaluation
préalable des normes des projets de
normes qui sont soumis à son avis voilà
merci beaucoup pour ces interventions
qui à la fois sont variées à la fois se
recoupe
se disait avec
au moins il y a un point commun les
exemples font évidemment différents il y
a aux compétences qui sont les vôtres
mais enfin entre l'absence la juste et
la révisabilité des
compensations je crois qu'il y a eu une
individité au moins sur ces trois points
madame la Présidente
tout d'abord la parole merci beaucoup
quelques mots rapides pour laisser place
aux questions de mais quand je voulais
vraiment vous remercier pour la qualité
la diversité de vos interventions
monsieur professeur on gagnerait à faire
savoir davantage que ce qui n'est pas
interdit est possible
et effectivement on s'enferme trop dans
des choses
qui ne permettent pas d'atteindre
l'objectif qui est celui de chacun c'est
à l'efficacité de l'action biblique
jusqu'au dernier kilomètre selon un
principe de subsidiarité qui est chère
au Sénat c'est le niveau le plus
pertinent qui est sans doute le mieux à
même de comprendre et d'analyser vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente et de
faire je voudrais juste en écho à ce que
vous avez dit par les très rapidement
enfin cinq points mais d'abord nous
avons conduit à la négation collectivité
un travail sur je l'ai dit la
simplification autour des normes et
qu'en tout cas ce que nous avons dit
au-delà de la désolation qui nous a tous
gagné du fait que ça va pas s'arranger
c'est terrible ça nous complique la vie
ça protège tellement que rien ne se
passe y compris le service qu'on doit
rendre toutefois néanmoins cependant
nous sommes dit comment est-ce qu'on
peut éviter de surcharger la barque et
en ce sens nous avons conclu avec le
gouvernement le Sénat une charte
d'engagement sur la fabrique de la loi
et vous avez évoqué cela d'une manière
extrêmement pertinente c'est en amont il
y a l'étude d'impact la justesse de
nouveau dispositifs est-ce que c'est
nécessaire ou pas et l'étude d'impact
doit être accompagnée d'une évaluation
budgétaire y compris de tous les effets
collatéraux n'ont vu nos spontanément
visible que vous évoquez première chose
ensuite nous avons beaucoup travaillé
c'est mon deuxième point sur
l'expérimentation c'est à dire avant de
se lancer dans des opérations un peu
style vous voyez Overlord où on en reste
soudainement la solution miraculeuse et
on va envers toute la France et que
c'est excellente idée et on se rend
compte que le temps après que c'est
coûteuse c'était peut-être pas si
pertinent que ça c'était trop uniforme
bref pouvons-nous encourager développer
la pratique de l'expérimentation qu'une
loi d'ailleurs améliorée
qui conduit à de l'évaluation et ce qui
permet quand vous avez expérimenté de
mieux évaluer notamment les coûts c'est
un
quelque chose d'assez simple et qui fait
partie de notre charte d'engagement et
le troisième point c'est sur le
transfert de compétences volontaire
il y a un principe de libre
administration dans la Constitution si
l'étape pense que quelqu'un va mieux
faire que lui il lui donne et s'il lui
dit comment faire il paye et on peut
aussi envisager que certains territoires
comme vous l'avez dit parce que vous
vous avez besoin vous puissiez demander
un transfert ce qui a été fait pour le
transfert des routes et que moi je
proposerai un moment pour les
départements la médecine scolaire ce que
je pense qu'il sera beaucoup mieux faite
par les départements mais je ne vous
affole pas madame je suis consciente que
c'est pas en l'état du financement de la
médecine scolaire que ça doit se faire
voilà mais un transfert uniquement
volontaire la clause de revoyure
en tout cas pour réajuster la
compensation fonction des obligations
supplémentaires que l'État vous a donné
et le dernier point c'est la merveille
de la fabrique de la loi je vais prendre
un exemple on a eu un texte génial sur
les mobilités
mobilité un enjeu de désenclavement un
enjeu de réussite enfin que c'est très
bien et on a eu un texte intelligent qui
a dit c'est pas dans un périmètre
administratif que ça se fait mais dans
un périmètre de bassin de vie formidable
donc il va y avoir les régions et les
interco l'interco a le renversement
mobilité la région qui a en charge tout
le rail
y compris sur les intercos qui
perçoivent le versement mobilité le
perso aucun versement mobilité et à
l'époque c'est Madame bonne qui
défendait le dossier moi je dirais pas
commission des lois et quand on le dit
bon alors ça c'est formidable à ce qu'on
va faire mais est-ce qu'on peut regarder
comment on va le financer ah non non là
c'est pas maintenant vous reviendrez en
octobre avec la loi de finances or en
octobre on discute avec qui avec le vrai
ministre des collectivités je veux pas
être désagréable c'est remercie
or à Bercy ils ont une responsabilité
c'est de dépenser le moins possible
c'est ce que j'appelle avec amitié des
codes killer donc le ministre de Bercy
nous dit ah les mobilités c'est
formidable mais moi il fallait voir ça
avec votre Ministre voilà et donc on se
retrouve à mettre en place des
compétences
alors même qu'on n'a pas l'argent et
tout ça ça génère à la fois de
l'espérance et dysfonctionnements et de
l'incompréhension et du dialogue ce sera
tout pour moi monsieur le Président
organique est prévu que toutes les
dispositions financières devaient être
dans le loi de finance et pas dans les
autres lois parce qu'avant il y avait
beaucoup de dépenses alors maintenant il
y a juste la dépense transférée
évidemment
la parole est de collection
vous éclairages qui effectivement
se complètent très bien
vous avez bien décrit qui a le sujet et
j'entends que c'est le sujet de la
mission d'information de la question des
compensations mais que ça s'inscrit dans
un contexte budgétaire plus vaste on va
dire
avec
une perte d'autonomie que ce soit parce
que vous avez des cristes c'est-à-dire
une fiscalité que les collectivités ne
peuvent plus
développer que ce soit par la réponse à
des appels à projets voire des
contractualisations qui font que au-delà
même enfin que tout ça ce conjugue en
fait il y a le sujet en soi de la
compensation mais qui a d'autres choses
qui viennent renforcer et réduire les
marges de manœuvre des collectivités et
donc ça m'amène à une première question
on voit
que des collectivités malheureusement
comme les régions j'ai été lu régional
donc je le dis tranquillement qui n'ont
jamais suscité l'engouement populaire
qu'on aurait pu attendre
que ça gagne les départements voire même
les communes qui restent la collectivité
préférée des Français mais moi je fais
partie de ceux qui pensent que le taux
d'abstention dernières élections
municipales n'a pas été seulement dû au
covid même si ça a pesait lourd et
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que
cette réduction de marge et le fait vous
avez dit Madame moi je le dis de manière
très inégale je dis les collectivités
ont parfois tendance à devenir à leur
corps défendant des mini-préfectures
vous vous dites on est des auxiliaires
des agents de l'État c'est un peu la
même idée est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que ça pèse très lourdement dans la
désaffection des électeurs des citoyens
à l'égard des collectivités parce qu'ils
perçoivent peut-être même confusément
qu'il n'y a plus beaucoup d'espace pour
des options politiques au sens noble du
terme qui différencie justement et qui
permettent aux citoyens de trancher le
projet de développement qui veut pour
son territoire et que ça enfin que ça
atténue tout ça et que ça en perd
complètement de l'intérêt que ça a
peut-être même les trop tôt sûrement
pour faire parler les chiffres mais
d'une désaffection des élus locaux des
mers notamment qui sont visiblement plus
nombreux que par le passé à raccrocher
est-ce que pour vous ça ne tient pas
aussi à ça et deuxième élément plus
concret et plus d'actualité je commence
à être interpellé comme peut-être un
certain nombre de nos collègues par des
communes notamment sur la traduction du
filet de sécurité
censé compenser alors deux choses dans
différentes c'est-à-dire le point
d'indice là on peut vraiment parler de
compensation d'une décision prise par
l'exécutif
mais aussi les questions énergétiques
qui sont un peu d'un autre ordre parce
que on peut avoir des débats sur la
politique énergétique du pays mais on
peut pas non plus complètement dire que
l'exécutif est responsable de la montée
actuelle des prix de l'énergie toujours
est-il que j'ai l'impression qu'on
franchit une nouvelle étape au sens où
des acomptes de d'éventuelles
compensation ont été attribuées à des
communes selon des critères extrêmement
complexes et qu'il s'avère aujourd'hui
que les communes et notamment celles qui
ont été les meilleurs élèves en termes
de gestion ne vont pas pouvoir en
bénéficier elles vont devoir non pas le
rembourser mais en tout cas on leur
défalquera ça des futurs DGF ou je sais
pas quelle forme ça prendra exactement
et que enfin pour moi c'est une nouvelle
étape franchise c'est-à-dire qu'on
propose une compensation des communes
essayent à juste titre de de l'obtenir
d'autres font d'entrée de jeu le choix
de ne pas la demander de peur de devoir
le rembourser ensuite et effectivement
on va se retrouver dans les futurs
budgets avec une situation qui peut être
compliqué sur le plan budgétaire et j'en
arrête là mais qui peut aussi être
compliqué
Antoine Lefebvre et puis bernardel
grosse se prépare merci monsieur le
Président merci pour
nos invités de cette table ronde pour
leur proposition et leur témoignages moi
j'avais deux observations de questions
il y a quelques temps nous avons engagé
la Bercy à engager la révision des
valeurs cadastrales il existe un grand
flou auteur de en termes de mise en
oeuvre je voulais savoir si vous avez
des inquiétudes particulières sur les
conséquences de cette réforme pour la
fiscalité des collectivités locales
puisque ça a été un peu soulevé par
certains parmi vous tout ça a été décalé
dans le temps mais est-ce que vous avez
déjà des craintes ou des espoirs que
cette réforme puisse amener un certain
nombre de d'améliorations en termes de
fiscalité des collectivités
je pense que là aussi comme la rappeler
la présidente on a besoin d'études
d'impact et une meilleure évaluation et
puisque madame Pentel vous avez
justement évoqué l'évaluation je
souhaiterais en profiter pour
poser une question à déléguer générale
de région de France lorsque l'on a mis
en oeuvre les les nouvelles grandes
régions on avait mis surtout en avant
une mutualisation forte des moyens et
des gains financiers importants en euros
c'était quand même une annonce
forte sur un plan peut-être marketing
politique aujourd'hui après plusieurs
années de fonctionnement qu'en est-il
véritablement est-ce que vous avez
évalué les économies on connaît beaucoup
de régions qui pour des raisons de
distance non pas par exemple revendu le
siège de la
région qui avait fusionné on continue à
faire des réunions dans des dans des
lieux de la région donc il y a pas eu de
sur le plan immobilier en tout cas des
gains est-ce que il y a des choses
précises sur le sujet merci
remerciement des collègues pour vos
interventions je suis resté maire d'une
toute petite commune rurale président de
l'interco et j'ai séché au Conseil
Général départemental pendant très
longues années donc je me retrouve
parfaitement dans vos propos et ça me
rappelle les débats que nous avions déjà
à la fin des années 90 et au début des
années 2000 ça date pas ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui
voilà
et non non bien sûr
donc aujourd'hui on a du recul ça a été
rappelé les premières lois
décentralisations ils ont exactement 40
ans donc on a dû on a du recul là-dessus
et on voit bien quand on a suivi un peu
ça de près que les choses elles sont
faites un peu au fil de l'eau qui a eu
des adaptations qui a eu des
superpositions de mesure une sorte de
pilotage à vue parce qu'au fur et à
mesure qu'on avançait que les
compétences bougent étaient transférées
on s'apercevait des problèmes de
compensation et donc on a d'une certaine
façon on est venu au fil du temps du
gouvernement confondu et quelque soit sa
couleur politique mettre un peu des
rustines pour éviter qu'il y ait trop de
dégâts sur les questions
décompensation et éviter que finalement
c'est des centralations créent des
inégalités territoriales supplémentaires
donc tout ça ça s'est fait un peu au fil
de l'eau par des mesures ponctuelles
d'adaptation ou de dernière minute ou en
urgence je pense que aujourd'hui on a le
recul nécessaire
pour finalement faire une remise à plat
un peu de tout ça et poser des bases
solides pour l'avenir des questions de
compétences et de leur compensation
voilà et des moyens qui sont attribués
pour exercer ces compétences donc je
pense que le moment est venu et qu'on a
suffisamment de recul et
de vécu d'expérience pour faire une
remise à plat des choses et puis je peux
pas m'empêcher de me dire que je
m'associe parfaitement aux propos de la
présidente de la Lozère sur la question
des critères est toujours du nombre
d'habitants et qu'il faut qu'on fasse
très attention à cela il y a les normes
d'habitants mais vous avez donné
l'exemple de votre DGS il est tout à
fait révélateur je pense qu'il faut
qu'on intègre d'autres critères
notamment ceux des espaces sinon
attention il y a un risque à la
décentralisation c'est que si les tâches
ou pas son rôle de régulateur la
décentralisation elle peut accroître les
inégalités entre les territoires qui ont
des moyens financiers plus importants
que d'autres
ensuite sur la question des compétences
qui sont compensées après j'ai une ou
deux questions
on s'aperçoit quand même au fil de temps
qui a eu différentes modalités de
compensation des compétences là aussi
tout gouvernement confondu on a du recul
il y a eu des compétences qui ont été
compensées des transferts de compétences
qui ont été compensés sur les budgets
par des dotations des dotations
budgétaires on a les exemples des
exonérations en alphabet exemple de fnjr
qui est qui est figé et puis on a plus
récemment
des
des transferts qui ont été compensés par
où tes décisions nationales qui ont été
compensées par de la fiscalité qu'elle
soit locale ça a été le cas avec les
communes et la taxe d'habitation ou
qu'elle soit nationale avec la TVA et
donc
je pense que quand on compense par de la
fiscalité même il y a des questions de
période de référence j'y reviens pas
parce que on n'a pas le temps mais en
tous les cas on crée quand même une
recette qui est dynamique sur laquelle
on peut discuter ce qui est pas le cas
avec avec des dotations
sur la question de la révision et puis
les fameuses commissions moi je pense
que ça me paraît vraiment justifié
pourtant légitime juste de pouvoir
réviser les compensations en faisant
attention parce qu'au fil du temps il y
a des décisions qui relèvent de la
politique locale cela on peut pas
imaginer les compenser mais il y a des
évolutions qui relèvent de décisions
nationales et chaque fois qu'il y a des
évolutions qui relèvent de décision
nationale qui sont législatives ou
réglementaires les normes et autres mais
moi je trouverai pas choquant à
l'inverse je trouverai tout à fait
opportun qui est un dispositif de de
révision des modalités de compensation
en distinguant encore une fois ce qui
relève des politiques locales et ce qui
relèvent des décisions nationales
c'est-à-dire des évolutions qui sont
rendues obligatoires en fait par des
décisions de niveau national alors après
moi j'aurais deux questions peut-être
pour oui pour vous monsieur cabanes la
première
en l'a évoquée d'ailleurs il y a des
domaines sur lesquels il y a des
compétences partagées c'est vrai pour
l'éducation c'est vrai pour les collèges
par exemple on se dit ben voilà la péd
agogie ça relève de l'État et puis les
équipements ça relève du département
sauf qu'on s'aperçoit que dans les faits
la limite elle est pas toujours simple à
définir et quand tous les cas je pense à
quasi-totalité des départements ont
financé des dépenses qui relèvent
vraiment de la pédagogie on parlait des
équipements numériques ou autres y
a-t-il des
des textes ou des éléments ou serait-il
facile en tous les cas plus facile de
venir préciser
ce qui relève finalement quand on dit la
pédagogie relève de l'État et et les
équipements relèvent et des bâtiments
relais des départements qu'on puisse
venir préciser cette chose là et vous
avez évoqué la question des duistes
c'est tout à fait flagrant surtout quand
il y a pas de problème de musique dans
le collège ou dans l'école et quand il y
a un demi ce qui intervient c'est c'est
révélateur
[Musique]
numérique voilà donc où on est au cœur
de la pédagogie donc voilà est-ce que ça
pourrait être précisé et deuxièmement
sur la question modification aménagement
vous nous avez dit sur quoi ça ne
correspondait pas mais en fait dans la
réalité ça correspond à quoi les les
modifications aménagement qui sont à
compensées que vous avez évoqué voilà
c'est ce sont mes deux questions
Isabelle briquet puis Lucien
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement donc un grand merci à tous
les intervenants ce que c'était des
interventions de qualité mais ça nous
rappelle du vécu quand même sur
les territoires et ça c'est sûr
la question s'adresse plus
à Monsieur cabanes aussi dans la dans le
droit fil de ce qu'a dit Bernard tout à
l'heure sur
sur les compensations
vous avez bien posé le problème
effectivement
quand aménagement modifications pas de
compensation obligatoire pour les
transferts ce qui pose souci c'est la
période de la période de référence et
l'absence aussi de réexamens des bases
de compensation de la compensation alors
j'ai Bernard rien dire qui pense qu'on
est mûr pour s'attaquer à la remise à
plat
oui c'est vrai
et vous vous le disiez professeur en
conclusion d'autres intervention c'est
est-ce qu'on peut ouvrir un droit à
compensation perpétuelle du coup ça
m'amène une une question parce que
est-ce que revoir ce système des
compensations ne va pas conduire à une
nouvelle inflation normative car il va
bien falloir poser des des garde-fous il
va falloir sécuriser juridiquement ces
dispositifs donc est-ce que vous avec
votre votre avis de
juridique là-dessus c'est que
est-ce qu'il va être possible de faire
quelque chose de censé qui correspondent
à notre à notre réalité mais avec
vraiment la sécurité juridique qui
l'entoure parce que sinon ça va être la
foire tout le temps enfin on voit bien
des fois des gens en claques pendant mes
anciens souvenirs
enfin patient ancien que ça en même
temps
à quel point c'était compliqué de mettre
de mettre ses principes en oeuvre donc
là si
la remise à plat des fois pour être pire
que ce que le système que l'on a donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faudra y veiller
juridiquement voilà juste un petit
éclairage s'il vous plaît merci
merci monsieur le Président
moi je voudrais poser une question mais
en fait à vous tous peut-être que ça
vous aidera à faire une petite
conclusion parce que en fait
ça fait depuis
1982 d'ailleurs monsieur le professeur
la signalé depuis le transfert de
compétences on fait en sorte
effectivement de compenser de pas
compenser puis après on oublie et puis
les compensations sont fixes ne suivent
pas l'évolution de la vie enfin bon
voilà et donc ça me rappelle aussi comme
Isabelle de de bonnes de bons moments de
calcul de budget mais moi ce que je
voudrais vous demander c'est avec tout
cela depuis toute cette histoire là
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du devenir des
communes dans cette affaire là
parce que est-ce que Antoine de fond il
y a pas ça derrière mais en quelques
mots quoi parce que sinon
je vois la présidente qui est inquiète
mais simplement en quelques mots voilà
et chacun ce qui vous concerne
[Musique]
un peu plus un peu plus merci monsieur
le président
bon alors on va je vais je connais
finalement que la commission des
finances ici donc je suis très très donc
je vais prendre le même principe que la
commission des finances c'est-à-dire
vous êtes intervenu dans un ordre et
bien c'est dans l'ordre inverse que vous
avez commencé la réponse qui si surprend
toujours surtout que j'avais oublié de
le prévenir mais chacun prend la partie
qui qui veut bien il y a pas de limite
mais il serait bien que on finit de s'en
étant raisonnable donc n'hésitez pas
je répondrai sur deux points le premier
c'est la question que vous posiez sur la
fusion des régions et le second sur le
pouvoir d'agir des élus
sur sur la fusion des régions peut-être
puisque vous l'avez cité rappelé qu'elle
avait été l'évaluation personnelle sans
doute du ministre qui avait annoncé
une économie possible un bien attendu de
10 milliards d'euros de la fusion des
régions on rappellera utilement que les
budgets cumulés de l'ensemble des
régions représentent 46 milliards
d'euros aujourd'hui
et donc une économie de 10 milliards
d'euros
représente un quart en fait du budget
cumulé des régions d'où l'importance de
de l'évaluation alors vous évoquez à
juste titre la question de la revente
des sièges je vais peut-être revenir
d'abord sur un vision un peu plus
globale
entre 2015 et 2019 les budgets de
fonctionnement de l'ensemble des régions
ont été stables quand je dis stable
c'est non indexé sur l'inflexion ils ont
été stables cette stabilité a permis une
augmentation de l'épargne brut entre
2015 et 2019 de 38% soit plus 1,8
milliards d'euros
a permis de passer de ratio de
désendettement moyen de 10,8 années à
4,3 années et a permis entre 2015 et
2019 d'augmenter de 2 milliards d'euros
l'investissement des régions pendant la
crise entre 2019 et 2021
l'investissement porté par les régions a
encore augmenté de 2 milliards d'euros
conduisant les régions à
représenter désormais 23% de
l'investissement public local là où en
2015 elle représentait 15% de
l'investissement public local je veux
croire que cette trajectoire qui est
très homogène entre les régions
fusionnées et celles qui ne l'ont pas
été fait la démonstration à la fois de
la bonne gestion de l'argent public par
les régions en dépit de toutes les
contraintes et de ce que au fond
le la confiance qu'il aurait été
adressée
elle a été à juste titre
évidemment les régions fusionnées n'ont
pas toutes revendu le siège des
anciennes régions mais dans les sièges
des anciennes régions il y a des agents
territoriaux qui constituent ceux qui
font fonctionner la région et qui ont
leur bureau il n'y a pas seulement un
hémicycle et des bureaux pour les élus
qui évidemment de siège plus forcément
au même au même endroit ce sont des
lieux de travail
dans certains cas ils ont été vendus
dans d'autres d'autres activités ont été
accueillies ils ont permis de
réaffecter les bureaux libres à des
satellites des régions agences
de développement économique Comité
Régional du Tourisme et toutes ces
structures qui sont financés par les
régions et qui ont pu trouver là des
locaux à la fois
d'un prix moins onéreux sans doute que
des prises à bail extérieures et
évidemment
cohérent avec les acteurs avec il
travaille habituellement ce qu'il aura
permis sans doute de gagner en
efficacité collective
s'agissant du pouvoir d'agir des élus
partageons votre analyse il y a
dans la crise démocratique que nous
traversons une crise de confiance en
doute du citoyen dans la capacité des
élus de tous niveaux à changer leur vie
en fait et non pas parce que ces élus ne
seraient pas animées par le
la même conviction de ce que la
démocratie locale l'action de proximité
peuvent changer la vie des gens mais de
ce que l’empilement des contraintes
normatives de ce que les contraintes
techniques juridiques de ce que les
difficultés budgétaires parmi celles que
nous avons évoquées ce matin les
contraintes à un point tel que nous
connaissons en grande vague de démission
d'élus et que effectivement le citoyen
perçoit aussi ce sentiment de perte le
pouvoir d'agir et nous croyons d'abord
que la décentralisation est une solution
à une partie des défis que traverse
notre pays enfin des défis qui attendent
notre pays et des difficultés qu'il
connaît et que c'est dans une nouvelle
vague de décentralisation pas forcément
obligatoirement de transfert de
compétences mais redonner du pouvoir
d'agir aux élus locaux pour apporter des
réponses dans la proximité aux besoins
des Français que nous résoudrons une
part de ce problème démocratique
merci je retiens votre formule pouvoir
d'agir du pouvoir d'agir c'est pour les
administrateurs du Sénat vous savez qui
nous aident à faire ces rapports quand
ce genre de formulation ils ont compris
dorénavant que
les données parce que ce sera emprunté
vous risquez d'être cité vous voyez
c'est quoi
des mers
de l'an dernier parce que c'est
ça arrive
la présidente
alors moi je veux je voulais d'abord
apporter
en fait faire par madame la présidente
d'un avis donc vous parliez des médecins
scolaires alors je ne peux pas ne pas
répondre donc sur la parce que
j'essayais un vrai sujet on en discute
au sein de la DF
donc excusez-moi sur les médecins
scolaires je partage nous ferions aussi
bien voir mieux mais pour autant nous
transférer les médecins scolaires au
moment où on en trouve plus où on peut
pas les recruter et nous transférer la
responsabilité je trouve que là voilà
par contre vous savez que nous demandons
depuis fort longtemps
je vous fais pas de cauchemar mais quand
même je veux le rappeler c'est un peu
facile de l'envisager maintenant par
contre nous réclamons les gestionnaires
de collège quand ça je le je le redire
la part de c'est quand même une inepsie
en fait d'avoir des équipes dans nos
cuisines qui est de ne pas avoir le
gestionnaire en hiérarchie directe avec
toutes les obligations que l'on a sur
l'alimentation voilà enfin un moment
donné on n'est pas très cohérent
mais nous avons par deux fois au Sénat
défendu défendu cette amendement pas
plus tard que dans 3ds nous n'avons pas
pu le faire passer parce que
il fallait que le gouvernement lève le
gage puisque ça génère une charge
supplémentaire pour les collectivités
tout le monde nous a dit que c'était
vraiment très très bien et nous avons
expliqué comment peut-on créer des
obligations d'approvisionnement circuit
court en produits bio à des présidents
de régions des présidents de
départements quand c'est le gestionnaire
de de
lycée qui dépendent l'État qui va
décider de ces achats et que déjà en
1982 le sujet avait été évoqué on avait
proposé guider des conventions de bonne
humeur qui soit signé entre le proviseur
et le président de région et que 40 ans
après on n'a pas pu me dire
une seule convention avec d'ici donc
nous sommes encore sur l'affaire mais il
faut que le gouvernement là c'est
abracada
c'est au moins ça en tout cas merci pour
votre soutien sur sur ce sujet donc sur
la capacité des élus à agir ou pouvoir
des élus je sais plus comment vous aviez
formulé les choses je partage ce que
vous dites il y a une vraie perte de 100
de l'engagement et du coup il n'y a
enfin je pense que nos concitoyens ne
voient plus la différence entre les
projets politiques parce que finalement
d'une majorité à l'autre vous avez
tellement de choses qui sont contraintes
et sur lequel on a on ne peut pas agir
qu'au final le l'engagement politique
perd complètement son sens et sur la
capacité d'agir enfin je pense que quand
on s'engage en politique en tout cas
enfin pour une majorité d'entre nous
c'est pour changer et améliorer la vie
des gens au quotidien donc quand en fait
on a plus le levier ça pose la question
de qu'est-ce qu'on fait des fois mes
réflexions où je leur dis mais ton effet
fonctionnaires quoi finalement quoi
voilà mais
sur le point suivant vous avez parlé du
filet énergie je reviens pour faire le
parallèle avec ce que je disais sur le
critère population par exemple vous
savez que alors les départements au
début était exclu ensuite ils ont été
rajouté etc il y a trois critères là de
nouveau donc trois critères cumulatifs
donc vous avez très peu de départements
en fait qui vont bénéficier de cette
aide je vérifier rapidement et puisqu'il
fallait augmenter l'énergie de plus de
60% il faut qu'il y ait une perte là de
l'épargne brut à 25 ou 30% j'ai plus
exactement et puis on a l'histoire du du
potentiel financier qui doit être
inférieur au double de du niveau de la
strat voilà mais là au final nous en
tout cas pour les départements une fois
de plus on va passer pour la plupart à
côté
le ministre nous a répondu hier je parle
sur le contrôle de mes collègues de la
commission des finances
voilà il y aurait eu 4000 sur les
comptes de gestion dont ils disposent au
titre de 2022
4700 communes qui pourraient y avoir
droit
4100 on aurait fait la demande voilà
donc
enfin on verra bien un jour peut-être
juste sur la question concernant la
révision cadastrale alors c'est vrai que
nous on est en département c'est quand
même plus les communes qui sont
concernées mais pour autant nous on le
regarde de près puisque avec la
suppression de la CPAE sur les deux
années qui arrivent donc avec une
annonce de compensation de la TVA donc
on verra si c'est comme pour nous la
dynamique disparaît mais en tout cas sur
les modalités de calcul là où je pense
que en tout cas pour des départements
comme la Lozère il faut qu'on soit tous
très vigilant c'est que il nous avait
été indiqué en CFA à un moment donné que
il pourrait y avoir le critère CFE qui
soit retenu et pour autant vous pouvez
avoir une entreprise en fait qui se
développe qui embauche sans forcément
construire et à grandir et quand on le
met en
pareil en lien avec les contraintes que
l'on va avoir avec le zéro
artificialisation net une fois de plus
là on pourrait avoir potentiellement un
critère
en fait qui qui nous pénalise et il faut
vraiment regarder l'évaluation de de ces
éléments là
je réponds pas sur les communes
[Rires]
[Musique]
je vais démarrer par un petit clin
d'oeil c'est vrai que quand j'étais
sollicitée j'ai dit mais qu'est-ce que
je vais pouvoir dire ou qu'est-ce que
nous allons pouvoir dire que les élus ne
savent ne savent déjà
et effectivement je vois que beaucoup de
choses ont déjà été dites redites
reditent depuis j'ai compris
pratiquement le siècle dernier enfin bon
je pense que on est au pied du mur
collectivement on est au pied du mur on
voit bien que si on ne fait rien cette
crise de confiance qui est aujourd'hui
une réalité que nous vivons au quotidien
nous ne savons pas de quoi demain est
fait et sera fait nous ne savons pas
demain quelle décision l'État va prendre
qui va nous contraindre à filmer un an
changer notre pied etc donc je crois que
on attend effectivement de des travaux
du Sénat comme de tous les
parlementaires des décisions qui vont
aller dans le bon sens il serait
vraiment temps parce que le
découragement dont vous avez parlé il
est réel on a une crise aujourd'hui
démocratique qui se traduit par un
éloignement de la population des
instances de décision on se bat tous les
toujours pour essayer de faire que ça ne
soit pas un désastre on multiplie les
réunions les ateliers citoyens enfin je
pense qu'on n'est pas avare de de
décision et moi je vais me lancer sur le
fait que oui il faut qu'on servait les
communes moi c'est ma conviction je
pense que c'est l'instant aujourd'hui
qui est la plus proche du du citoyen
dans lequel il se retrouve il se
retrouve pas du tout dans la communauté
de communes par exemple puisque nous on
avait fait un sondage sur les
compétences de la Communauté de Communes
on a été Farré mais bon c'est la réalité
aujourd'hui la communauté commune le
département la région etc c'est la
commune qui est aujourd'hui l'interface
entre entre
les décisions et les citoyens donc moi
je plaide pour vraiment la conforter
voilà et puis je dirais un petit mot de
du Comité des finances locales puisque
nous y sait Jean c'est très compliqué
c'est une instance qui est compliquée
qui est nécessaire et je pense qu'il
faut l'installer plus durablement sur
ses fonctions de de conseil et
d'accompagnement c'est très compliqué on
n'a pas de calendrier suffisamment net
donc il faut se s'organiser du jour au
lendemain pour pouvoir y participer moi
vous l'avez compris je suis à l'autre
bout de la France donc
voilà donc je pense qu'il y aurait
nécessité à essayer de voir comment on
peut faire fonctionner mieux ce comité
des finances locales et je terminerai
par bons travaux mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs on compte sur vous
merci alors la commune voilà
alors
on est sur d'organiser un peu la pensée
ah encore pardon celui-ci ça marche
parfait parfait bien il y a un transfert
de compétences qu'on n'a pas évoqué et
vous avez été deux en fin de compte à en
parler indirectement c'est le transfert
de la compétence du mécontentement
fiscal
en effet
à travers les révisions de cadastral
nous on a tous connu dans nos
intercommunalités les ciud où nous avons
eu des effets très pernicieux sur des
réformes fiscales avec des effets de
seuil sur de la fiscalité d'entreprise
et donc oui bien sûr qu'on a une
inquiétude de savoir ce que ça va donner
malheureusement après avec des études
d'impact qui sont qui sont un peu limite
et là aussi
vous évoquez
non pas le désamour
j'espère que cette simplement érodé mais
effectivement ça touche aussi
le bloc le bloc communal
il y a une difficulté aussi dans le
transfert de compétences qui n'existe
plus du levier fiscal
nous avons vu cette année des effets
vraiment pervers là aussi sur le
coefficient
je suis en train oui correcteur merci
ou en fait courte si on souhaite non pas
augmenter mais si on souhaite baisser
les impôts c'est quand même notre droit
et bien on a quand même des effets
terribles après sur cette décision qui
en fait courte limite cette volonté de
baisser les impôts et puis
ce sénateur vous avez évoqué le fait de
peut-être imaginer une nouvelle étape un
nouveau pacte ça ne se pour ça ne pourra
se faire qu'avec et ça on compte encore
sur vous sur une redéfinition aussi de
la péréquation
qui qui doit être absolument revu parce
que la péréquation mal conçue grippe nos
systèmes et en fin de compte à un effet
là aussi sur les transferts de
compétences ou au moins sur nos
capacités financières dernier point
monsieur le sénateur sur l'avenir de la
commune je reviendrai volontiers pour un
peu plus de temps pour vous exprimer les
réflexions dessus mais nous trois petits
points nous étions tout à l'heure dans
l'antichambre avec Monsieur le
professeur et la première chose qu'on
s'est dit c'est justement est-ce qu'on
croit à l'avenir des communes la plus
petite commune de Côte-d'Or 698 communes
9 habitants 9 habitants si ça coûte pas
cher si ils sont contents
des couleurs fiches la paix
par contre si une commune de 250
habitants 2000 habitants ne marche pas
par contre là il faut se poser la
question et on a des pistes il y a la
commune nouvelle madame la Présidente
est-ce que cette commune nouvelle
version 2 qu'on peut peut-être imaginer
mais moi je me poserai plutôt la
question non pas de l'avenir de la
commune mais de l'avenir des
intercommunalité aujourd'hui
mon intercommunalité a rendu des
compétences aux communes on a rendu des
compétences c'est un mouvement qui est
sûrement nouveau parce que on s'est
aperçu que pour certaines compétences
les communes sont meilleures que nous
c'est pas vrai partout c'est pas vrai
pour toute compétence mais nous nous
payons le coût d'avoir voulu de faire
tout ce qui est à l'échelle
intercommunale alors qu'on a oublié
simplement que sur certaines compétences
mais les communes sont pas si mauvaises
je vais pas me défiler je vais vous
répondre aussi
non donc la position de l'ADF et la
plupart de nos départements c'est de
dire que les communes enfin comme une
département c'est un couple ce sont de
véritables partenariats clonas et avec
cette proximité en fait que représente
les communes sur le terrain pour nos
concitoyens donc si je prends que ça je
vous répondrai bien entendu qu'il faut
conserver les communes moi à titre
personnel cette fois je dis c'est pas la
position de la DFA petite personnelle je
pense que poser la question de cette
manière là c'est pas la bonne façon et
en fait la seule façon qui doit nous
interroger c'est quel est le bon niveau
de strat pour apporter la bonne réponse
pour nos concitoyens et pour moi en fait
les structures non c'est pas une fin en
soi voilà et à un moment donné il faudra
peut-être accepter qui est des
modifications alors pas forcément la
commune du département d'ailleurs mais
bon
mais enfin voilà je pense que il faut
qu'on prenne le débat par un autre bout
et pas de dire qu'est-ce qu'on garde
qu'est-ce qu'on supprime mais plutôt
quelle est la bonne strate pour apporter
le bon niveau de réponse
à nous proposer des grandes lois de
grandes réformes allez-y voilà
évidemment écoutez je vais vous répondre
en six points mais je serai bref sur
chaque point je vous rassure premier
point je veux réagir à ce que dit madame
Sophie Pantel elle employé le
thermoxilaire moi depuis quelques temps
je considère que archers un très bon
terme auxiliaire mais je considère que
les collectivités territoriales ne sont
devenus des opérateurs de l'état d'un
nouveau genre
ce qui est pire
parce que les collectivités
territoriales font ce qu'on leur dit de
faire avec l'argent qu'on leur donne et
le seul point qui fait que c'est pas
encore vraiment des opérateurs au sens
ou organiques de 2001 si vous voulez
c'est que
on va essayer de croire que ne sont pas
sous tutelles sous tutelle
administrative que il y a encore une une
marge de manœuvre donc auxiliaire je
trouve que c'est un terme peut-être
optimiste
voilà deux deuxième point j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses
c'était vraiment très très intéressant
mais je crois qu'il faut faire attention
à pas mélanger certaines choses
la fiscalité ce qu'on appelle la
fiscalité partagée prend de plus en plus
de place dans les recettes des
collectivités soit
soit il y a de moins en moins de
recettes pour l'État évidemment soit
passe du fait de compensation de
transfert de compétences soit du fait de
réformes de la fiscalité locale
c'est-à-dire il y a deux deux fenêtres
par lesquelles la fiscalité partagée
rentre tout cela étant le tout cela
étant les enfants du même père l'article
72-2 et son fichu maintenant pour
répondre aux questions alors
la première question
concernant par exemple les lycées est-ce
que il y a des textes qui viennent faire
un partage de dans les compétences de ce
qui relèveraient de l'État et de ce qui
relèverait de l'entité à laquelle la
chose de la collectivité à laquelle la
compétence se déléguée alors comme plus
personne n'y comprend rien je ne peux
pas prétendre connaître tous les textes
mais je ne crois pas je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait des textes qui viennent
faire un partage des choses en disant
voilà si la frontière était compliquée
ça ça de la collectivité ou de cette
catégorie de collectivité ça ça
relèverait de l'État pourquoi ce n'est
pas le cas bien parce que en tant que
législateur avec un grand l vous ne vous
irez pas
parce que le législateur en général ne
se risque pas vers les définitions vers
les partages précis parce que vous savez
très bien que partager c'est certes
créer du flou mais c'est aussi
s'enfermer alors est-ce que ça serait
faisable probablement mais les textes
seraient complètement illisibles parce
qu'il y aurait certainement toujours des
cas auxquels on n'aurait pas pensé après
vous m'avez dit bon les modifications
les aménagements vous nous avez dit ce
que ce n'est pas mais qu'est-ce que
c'est j'ai de la chance j'ai retrouvé
dans mes notes des des exemples c'est
par exemple le législateur ou un décret
ou l'exécutif qui va prévoir de
nouvelles obligations de formation pour
du personnel ça ne change rien ça ne
change rien la compétence son exercice
son champ etc etc mais ça augmente le
coût pour la collectivité territoriale
voilà c'est le législateur ou l'exécutif
qui va augmenter une tarification voilà
c'est c'est typiquement ce genre de
choses ensuite
le comment on appelle ça le grand soir
c'est à dire tout remettre à plat
ça sur le papier oui c'est formidable
mais je crois qu'il faut être honnête
dans la réalité
ces guerres possibles de dire bon
maintenant on a le recul on remet tout à
plat
avec le recul qu'on a sur les
difficultés des transferts de moyenne
qu'on essaie de remettre à plat un
système stable de transfert Noyen pour
l'avenir avant d'engager une nouvelle
décentralisation c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose d'accord bon effectivement
il faudrait un travail d'évaluation
profonde très très profonde enfin là il
y en a pour des pour des années
et pour répondre je crois que je vais
pas parler communes je lui ai fait à peu
près le tour sur la question du droit à
compensation perpétuelle ce droit la
droit à la conversation perpétuelle
alors c'est une question est-ce que
on mettrait en place un endroit à la
compensation perpétuelle à titre
personnel je n'en sais rien si le
législateur veut que le métier soit le
l'ouvrage soit remis régulièrement sur
le métier pour évaluer régulièrement le
coût d'une compétence partagée ma
question était mais jusqu'à quand on va
faire ça c'est à dire est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire à une
compétence qui a été partagée en 8 allez
on réévalue on recalcule et en dans 40
ans est-ce qu'on le refera je crois que
le problème ne serait pas ici normatif
le problème serait comptable
c'est-à-dire il faut avoir des outils
comptables qui permettent de savoir
exactement comment on va suivre les
choses et comment on va réévaluer après
la norme juridique que tout de toute
façon comme je le disais déjà tout à
l'heure on y comprend rien donc on peut
rajouter encore de la complexité on y
comprend plus rien donc on peut rajouter
de la complexité c'est pas gênant c'est
pas gênant
dernière question l'avenir des communes
je n'en sais rien mais il y a une chose
qui est certaine c'est que le
législateur je crois d'un point de vue
financier fait tout pour les épargner
puisque on a vu que les départements et
les régions finalement sont financés par
l'État ou quasiment par l'État les
communes pour l'instant on conservent
encore une marge de manœuvre
sur leur recette leur recette fiscale
donc le soin un petit peu épargné mais
je suis comme madame la Présidente
tantelle je crois que c'est pas la bonne
façon d'aborder la question je crois que
l'organe en tant que tel c'est pas très
important c'est quel niveau de
collectivité ou quel niveau de PC pour
faire quoi une fois qu'on aura répondu à
cette question on pourra savoir
effectivement si les communes ont en
avenir ou pas voilà brièvement
merci beaucoup et le mot de la femme va
revenir à Madame Pantel qui est la plus
nombreuse
extrêmement forts extrêmement
précis extrêmement nourri d'exemple
aussi ce qui va nous aider pour
travailler sur le rapport c'est très
important pour nous je veux juste
revenir sur sur deux points ce que vous
avez dit madame la Présidente à propos
du CFN effectivement il faudra il faut
qu'on y travaille dessus il faut qu'on
améliore le pour que les collectivités
s'y retrouve mieux et puis se puissent
mieux participer à ce à ce comité donc
là c'est un point important et puis et
puis des communes alors moi je soutiens
évidemment les communes et je il faut
qu'on soit toujours à leur côté et c'est
un c'est le la collectivité de proximité
dans nos départements ruraux qui est
extrêmement importante pour pour nos
concitoyens donc il faut il faut
absolument pas perdre de vue notre notre
ruralité notre hyper ruralité qui a
besoin de ces de cette collectivité là
donc merci merci à tous mes collègues
sénateurs merci madame la Présidente
gatine merci cher Jérôme puis merci
vraiment à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous pour votre d'être venu et très très
important et et très intéressant merci
beaucoup